radicalization I don't know much
I what they say about it on television like
everyone else
until the day she comes to live
with you and touches all my children
we
[Music]
magnificent martin rocker we had recorded
visit mark  world
of rumors that maintained that 7
[Music]
the verdict was nurse m eur acciona
writhing sol there is in evening that the
sea [
Music]
they pay scarring one network
corp generic of their troops
the two boys like girls is a local
obscur and his assistant marie kerque
will tell you the level of
mobile excellence in asia my
name is nabila mazouz
my son was arrested at the airport at
the age of 17
while trying to leave for
series one  Once the shock passed
[Music]
I fought for him and I
developed an action plan in order to radicalize him
today with the work that I
did in collaboration with jessica
and other members  from the European network
I share my experience in
local schools in order to make people aware of
the many facets of
radicalization as for my son he
started studying as a social worker
[Music]
ok [
Music]
never good sense
[Music]